Kathlyn morale
welcome Thank You Kathleen you're a
journalist and a writer and you started
up very early
writing your first book when you were 15
yes and and then you suddenly hit a
nerve with this book called how to be a
woman a book about yourself yes but you
hit some kind of nerve didn't you well
yes
yeah no I'd been writing about kind of
politics and celebrity and television
for The Times and but I found that
increasingly I was spending more and
more time getting really angry about
feminism because I was meeting women of
my age and younger and when I asked them
if they were feminists they would say no
and I'd be like well I think you
probably are dude
and they'd be like no I'm not and I go I
think every woman is born feminist by
default we live you know in Northern
Europe in ER in a feminist world if you
went to school and then you know you got
a job and and you don't feel that your
husband owns you legally and you vote
then you are a feminist and the only way
that you could say that you're not a
feminist is if you actually went to
Parliament and saw the Prime Minister
and said I'd like to give my right to
vote back that's the only way that you
could stop being a feminist I read it in
your book that you you learned a lot
about feminism from your husband yes we
just went you don't stop worrying about
being weird or crazy or stuff just be
nice and be polite and it just never
occurred to me no one ever sort of says
something as simple as that just be a
nice person and be polite and looked and
the feminism that I write about in the
book is basically based on that kind of
just trying to be polite that's why you
know often I think women don't know if
some sexism is happening to them and the
the way that you can tell if someone's
being sexist to you is if they're just
not being polite to you if what they're
saying is making you feel uncomfortable
so yes so like that's actually it
applies to men as well well yes I mean
every way I mean the one best the one
most important thing we can do as human
beings is just all be polite because no
war would start if we weren't all just
polite at all times it's very hard to
start a war when everyone's being very
polite
is wrong with feminism today I think it
became to be seen as kind of a duty it
was people stopped talking about it for
a while and so then it was mainly
something for the older generation he
was seen to be angry and to hate men and
to hate fashion and and lots of very
negative things and almost like a duty
like like eating fresh fruit and
vegetables are eating fiber or like if
you're in the Girl Guides and you have
to get your badges without being able to
talk about female circumcision and sex
traffic and kind of serious things and I
don't see a feminism like that at all to
me feminism is like rock and roll that's
it's a revolution anything that makes
you you know comfortable in yourself and
able to talk about the realities of your
life and makes you equal to men that's
exciting
sorry don't you think that you have your
generation have these older generations
to thank for that you can feel that
feminism is rock'n'roll Oh totally I had
to fight more be more angry and act like
they did no well this is one of the
questions cuz I think that often
commentators like to get young feminists
to argue with older feminists and they
keep saying you know don't you think
that the old feminists are passe now and
I'd like no you know everything that
happens to the fact that I can be more
relaxed and make fun of feminism now
it's entirely because women of my mother
and my grandmother's generation did
these things for me and also I would
have been really angry too if I was
having to deal with what they had to
deal with so what would be the most
important issues is is is it like high
heels is that an important issue well I
mean I I write about high heels in the
book because mainly because I can't walk
in them and so as a personal anger for I
can't walk the earth for anyone who can
walk in them your eyes yes no and it
looks you know someone who can walk in
them it's like ballet it's it's an
athletic achievement to be able to do it
I would hazard to guess that most women
can't most women that I see walking down
the street in high heels are kind of
walking like Tina Turner Saints I mean
so so so you so wait so why you argue
against high heels and that but
the main thing that you in one of the
big arguments they have is against
Brazilian waxing a certain amount of
women will like to do that and they will
be happy with how it looks and that's
fine
but I mean in our country at least it's
now that seem to be normal you can only
be normal if you do have a Brazilian wax
and to me the idea that I would have to
pay money every month to fear be normal
and it to be painful seems really it's
like having to pay a tax from being a
woman and also on top of that it's just
the administration on it is insane most
women if they've got a party on Friday
where they think that they might pull
someone and have sex with them on a
Tuesday having to go oh can I go to a
party like this or am I gonna have to go
and get it waxed again kind of where am
I in the cycle of administration and it
just takes up a lot of time that I would
rather spend eating cheese or reading
poetry or watching ghostbusters also
about women always supporting each other
yes asking each other yes the idea of
the sisterhood and you must women must
never slag off other women well are the
men doing it and men are allowed to
slack each other off and be about
each other and for the idea that women
shouldn't be and should never say
anything bad about another woman and be
serene and calm well that's not human
that's like another thing that we've got
to do we've got to be beautiful and sexy
and thin and serene and calm at all
times as well and also it just like this
thing where people go it's because women
keep putting other women down that
there's all this inequality for women
and I think it's probably more to do
with the fact that women have paid 30%
less that's what's putting women down
rather than me in the toilet with my gay
friends going her hair looks a bit flat
doesn't apply to you do do you do you
fit in there definitely this is your way
of being a feminist what's not to like
first of all type of reading your book
two days ago because I also googled you
by the way I read an interview about
because you're you're very very funny
and
both here and in the book and I read an
interview where you said that you wanted
to win people over to feminism with
jokes yes and I love that
using jokes for a purpose like that
brilliant Maria how do you fit into this
this idea of feminism are you a feminist
yourself actually I would like to ask
you Missy if I am or not but because I
love men and I love women and I think
that's the way we are created I love the
way we met and the way we have respect
for each other and I don't think it has
to be a fight yes I love when a woman
wants to be feminine but they're also
it's men I mean women that wants to
maybe be a little bit more you don't
have to dress like this you can dress
how you want but still be a beautiful
woman and soft and kind inside no well
this is what made me sad when we were in
makeup and you came up to me when I'll
be nice to me out there because I think
you thought because I was a feminist and
you're blond that I was gonna sit there
going you can't be a feminist this this
idea that kind of there's a right kind
of feminist that kind of you could only
be a feminist if you're middle class and
you have sensible shoes on and you went
to university and you're standing there
with a copy of Virginia Woolf in your
hands
kind of like eating porridge it just
seems you know I can't see how you
wouldn't be a feminist and and then this
idea that feminists hate men as well I
find so weird you get some feminists who
will go oh men can't say they're
feminists why not why are we trying to
make the party smaller like my feminism
includes everybody I love men men
invented the Beatles men actually you
started in a very male-dominated
profession yes journalism yes actually
you did the same you started as a sports
anchor when there were almost no female
sports anchors no there were none there
had been one before maybe she quit and
then I came a year and a half or so
afterwards and it was order from high
levels in this house that there should
be a female host of the sports shows and
so when I walked in i I was very happy
to be that person actually and I fear no
man but
two words I can laugh at the fact that
my boss at the time looked at me and
said well Katarina I think that your
size is about the same as your colleague
Jana over here and you can borrow his
jacket where you are and I think that
that is the funny story here in Sweden
that I actually wore his jacket for a
year and a half on television on
television on the show a male jacket I
eat but I think that the feminism thing
about it is that I never ever doing that
one and a half year thought to ask if I
could maybe have a female test I just
accepted but I'm from the 50s you see I
was born in the 50s and with its various
said a very sad generation no one talks
about us we'll just forgot
thank you so much for coming please
welcome Steven Pinker